Let's get started.
[Music]
>> Hey, what's up guys? I found this beer
left over from some campers and I'm
totally wasted.
>> No way. This is wild. Collab of the
century. Let's go.
>> Everything that you have seen is
completely AI generated, fully
automated, and the best part, it's free.
So today, let's build an automation
using Google's most powerful video tool,
which is VO3. And we're going to use any
as well, an automation tool. And guess
what? We're going to make everything for
absolutely free. And hey, if you stick
around till the end, there's a huge,
huge surprise waiting for you, and you
don't want to miss that.
[Music]
All right, chapter one. We're going to
get access to V3. All right, guys. So,
here's the deal. We found a Google Cloud
Platform, and it's about to get crazy.
You can make mind-blowing videos using
Google's V3 model through Google Vertex
AI Studio. And here's how you get
started. All right. So, the first thing
you need to do is head over to Google
Cloud Console. Create a free account.
Yes, it's absolutely free. Yo, and get
this. When you create an account, you
get $300 worth of free credits for 90
days. That's more than enough to get
crazy with your experiments. All right.
So, once you're in, you can check out
the sidebar menu. It has all of the
Google tools, but for this video, we're
just going to be sticking to Vertex AI.
All right. So, click Vertex AI. From
here, go to media studio and then
generate video. Boom. Sorted. You're in.
Now, this is where the magic happens cuz
now you can select V3 from the models
available. Type a prompt and you're good
to go. All right. So, check this out. A
cinematic shot of a Yeti vlogging in the
Himalayas.
4K
dramatic lighting. That's all we're
going to do for now. And let's see what
it chs out.
>> Welcome back to my vlog. And today we're
up in the Himalayas.
You know, I'm actually comparing this to
the other Yeti videos that I've seen.
And this one actually looks like the
Yeti. The other ones look like oranguta
tanks and stuff. It's pretty wild,
right? But let's be real. Doing this
manually is cool, but sometimes it takes
too much time. So here's our game plan.
Instead of generating videos one by one,
we're going to automate the entire
process from idea to prompt to final
generation and store everything in a
Google sheet which is the automation.
For the automation, let's use any free
and open source. It works like magic.
All you need to do is drag, drop, and
connect. All right. So before diving in,
let's break the entire automation
process into three simple steps. The
first one going to be idea and prompt
generation. Second is going to be video
generation. And the third one is going
to be storing everything. If you're new
to the channel, then make sure you check
out this video where we've used N10
before and we've gone into complete
detail. So, if you feel like you're
getting a little lost, please check out
this video and then come back to this
one. So, now we're tackling the first
step, which is idea and prompt
generation. All right. So, what we're
going to do is we're going to start by
putting a trigger. Now, you can either
set a manual trigger or a schedule
trigger that runs daily or on a custom
schedule, whatever you want. We're going
to go with a schedule trigger so the
workflow runs on its own again and
again. Whenever the trigger fires, we
need an AI agent to start the process
because we need a fresh idea to make the
video. All right. So now we're going to
set up an agent node with Google Gemini
as our AI model and let's name it as
ideas AI agent. Also going further for
every user message, system message or
JSON or anything we've already made a
document right here and we'll keep copy
pasting whatever we need from there. So
for this what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put in give me as many ideas of
a yeti speaking to a camera and doing a
vlog. Okay. So that I've put in the user
message area. But you can ask for
anything. You can literally do anything
you want. You can ask for a man on the
streets of New York talking to random
people. You can ask for an alien talking
to other aliens in a box pop style. Or
if you want something controversial then
you can even do a dude on the beach in
Goa not letting anyone surf. Anything.
It's up to you. So let's just do a quick
recap. We've got the trigger and we've
got the agent node. So now what we need
to do is add a think tool. So this node
invites the AI agent to think before
answering. It's especially useful for
complex prompts. All right. What this
basically does is it lets the AI talk to
itself first before spitting out a
response. We want these ideas in a
structured format. So we'll edit the
JSON output and pass it accordingly.
We'll also quickly update our system
message in these to reflect that. So now
we need to set up our Google sheet for
storing all the information we got from
the AI agent we just set up. So now
let's go to the Google drive and create
a sheet named V3 NA10 automation.
We'll update all the columns in the
sheet based on the JSON output we expect
and connect them all inside of any.
So the Google Sheets node in any just
tells it to work on that sheet. We won't
ask it to create or delete spreadsheets.
We're just going to append and update
rows in the spreadsheet that we've
already created. Okay, so we've already
linked our credentials to connect with
Google.
Now we just need to map out all of the
columns manually. All right, so just
take a look over here. Just follow what
I'm doing.
Cool. So now we've built the entire idea
generation pipeline and we're going to
be storing all the ideas in Google
Sheets itself. Okay. So let's try to
execute it once to check if it works.
Sorted. It works. And you can see our
first idea right there in the sheet. All
right. So now we want another AI agent
and this one we're going to name the
prompts AI agent. This one will generate
prompts from the ideas that we've given
because we've got the ideas now and we
need the actual prompts to send to
Vertex Studio. Okay, again we're going
to go back to our notion sheet where
I've put all of the user messages and
we're going to copy this user message
and paste it here.
So we've already figured out the thing
tool and the model that we're going to
be using. So we're just going to connect
them to the prompts AI agent. Now we're
on to step two, which is video
generation. Now, Google Vortex currently
has no direct integration with any 10.
So, we're going to have to manually
create an integration using an HTTP
request. All right. So, we're going to
need to gather some values from your
Google proud project. And in order to do
that, you'll find this button called get
code. So, once you click on the get code
button, you have access to details like
your project ID, your location, your
model, and your API endpoint. An
important point to note over here is
you're also going to need your access
token. So, make sure you open cloud
shell and run this code. And once you
run this line, you'll get a huge access
token from the cloud shell and you can
use it. All right. So now that we've got
all of these details, we're going to
need a wait node to let V3 generate the
video before we fetch it. This usually
takes like less than 60 seconds for VO
to render the video. So once the video
is done, we need to fetch it. So add
another HTTP request node in N8N.
And we're going to use the same
endpoint, but this time we're going to
be asking, hey Vio, is my Yeti ready?
Fair enough.
After you enter that, you're going to
get a base 64 encoded video file in the
response. So now we're going to decode
whatever this B 64 encoded video file
is. And to decode it, we're going to
convert it into ampp4 file using N10's
built-in functions. You've got to pack
extra yak butter for the high passes.
Trust me on this one. Now we're moving
on to step three. Upload a drive log the
sheet. So now let's add the Google Drive
node to upload the MP4 file.
Let's name the file same as the idea.
Now, finally, we're going to add the
Google sheet note to update our previous
Google sheet with the sharable drive
link. All right. And you're done with
that. You now have a fully logged,
autogenerated voowered Yeti video
pipeline. Insane.
Too long.
>> Yeah, a little bit too long.
>> So, now you have a fully logged video
generation model that you can use for
anything. We've used it for Vieti
specifically, but you can use it for
absolutely anything. Create a faceless
account, get millions of followers, and
get some cash money, bro. The surprise.
I know a lot of you have been waiting
for it, so here you go. All right, that
was a lot. And you could follow all of
that step by step, or you could also use
the surprise. We've linked the exact
anytime and JSON file for the entire
workflow in the description. So, if
you're thinking about getting a little
creative with your ideas, make sure you
try it out and let us know what you
think. You can literally import it and
have this entire AI video engine running
in less than 10 minutes. No repeating
steps, no copying prompts. Just import,
connect your credentials and go. All
right. So with Jugard Pro Max, we
managed to show you how to use Google V3
in India to generate cinematic AI
videos. We automated the full pipeline
using any. And we even linked the exact
JSON setup so you don't have to start
from scratch. And now you can build your
own idea to video engine in under 10
minutes. If this helped you, make sure
you hit like and subscribe. But more
importantly, drop your wildest video
channel idea in the comments. Make it
weird. Make it original. Just don't make
it boring.